cNN has seized upon the awful shooting
at a Texas High School last week to spew
fake news and push its political agenda
at a record rate we will break down the
activists false claims the line-by-line
then Kyle Kashyap and Kenneth Preston
stopped by to discuss the media reaction
after that Trump's prophetic streak
continues as an ms-13 gang member named
animal that's his name is actually
animal is sentenced to 40 years in
prison and a literal sinkhole opens up
on the White House lawn because God does
not always paint with the subtlest brush
finally the lion ization of pederast
cult apologist Harvey Milk on this day
in history
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
there is so much to get to today and
that also that phrase pederast cult
apologist that might be the worst
epitaph to possibly have that is the one
title I think I want to avoid in my life
Petter s cult apologist nevertheless the
left makes this guy out to be the
greatest hero of history we will discuss
all the many myths of Harvey Milk before
I get to any of those things let me tell
you about my bed let me bring you on and
you know that I'm getting married soon
getting a little excited welcome come on
into my boudoir everybody I'm talking
about Boleyn branch
I love Boleyn branch I love it so much
Boleyn branch is the key to getting a
great night's sleep it's easier and more
affordable than you think
you don't need an expensive mattress or
sleeping pills to do that you just need
to change your sheets me being a
derelict bachelor bum in my life I'd go
to you know the near store and I'd spend
$3 and get sheets made of sandpaper
because I didn't think it mattered what
kind of sheets you have it matters it
matters so much Boleyn bread sheets are
so it's so nice just slept on them about
an hour ago you know I roll out of bed
then I come here under this show
everything Boleyn branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from 100%
organic cotton they start out super soft
they get softer over time you can buy
directly from them so luxury sheets can
cost $1,000 or more but because they cut
out the middleman you buy directly from
them Boland brand sheets are made only a
couple hundred bucks well well worth it
everyone who tries Boleyn branch loves
them that's why they have thousands of
five-star reviews Forbes The Wall Street
Journal Fast Company all talking about
Boleyn branch even three u.s. presidents
sleep on bowling brand sheets three US
presidents and one best-selling author
of a blank book that is a high
recommendation of these fabulous
fabulous sheets shipping is free you can
try them for 30 nights so look whatever
gutter you're lying and where you're
watching this show from just think about
that free shipping you get to try some
bedding for 30 nights that's a big win
but you won't want to send them back you
will love them they're really nice no
risk no reason not to give them a try to
get started right now my listeners don't
say I never did nothing for you I'm
givin you a wedding present for my
wedding get $50 off your first set of
sheets at Boleyn branch com promo code
Michael Mich
El Michael that's like my first name
Michael bowl and branch calm $50 off
your first set of sheets you're gonna
buy many more sets though I bet Bo ll
and branch comm promo code Michael mi CH
AE L that's my name okay they're really
really good so much fake news to discuss
that was the only real news you're gonna
hear for the rest of the show now we
gotta get into fake news so this is
right out of the left wing playbook you
there was this awful shooting last week
and this is what they do they wait for a
tragedy to happen they pounce on it and
they spread fake news and I'm using fake
news in a very specific way I mean they
are lying about statistics they're lying
about incidents and then they accuse
anybody who questions that fake news of
politicizing the incident this happens
every time they there's this tragedy we
say okay maybe we should all just calm
down a little bit mourn for what's
happened then they spread a bunch of
lies we say why you know that isn't
correct actually they say how dare you
you're politicizing this I'm
politicizing this so you you see this
has been happening all the time we hear
this from CNN they say including today's
shooting incident in a Texas high school
this year there have already been 22
school shootings where someone was hurt
or killed that averages out to more than
one shooting a week that's a terrifying
statistic right sure it just isn't true
the way they arrived at this statistic
is they included it incidents where at
least one person is shot not including
the shooter that it occurred on school
grounds grades K through college through
university level it includes gang
violence it includes just brawls it
includes domestic violence they even
include the accidental discharge of any
firearm of any firearm at all we're not
just talking about a big scary gun so
here here are some of the things that
are included to let you arrive at that
untrue statistic that there have been 22
school shootings this year on April 9th
in Globe Roseville New York a student
shot another student with a BB gun and
that other student had a bruise on his
on his body that counts they include
that in the statistic they're trying to
conflate someone using a little pellet
gun and it leaves a bruise
to a major school shooting which is
awful one because it's dishonest but
it's disrespectful to the people who
actually were victims of the shooting
March 13th in Seaside California a
teacher accidentally discharged a
firearm during a public safety class no
one was killed everyone was okay they're
comparing that to ten people being
killed March 8th and Alabama a non
student was shot at an apartment on the
University of South Alabama campus
non-student no but the image that they
conjure on the left when they say this
is some lunatic murderer going into an
elementary school and killing children
but the the statistic is including
people just some guy living on the
campus when even a student February in
EDA Bena Mississippi a non student was
shot at a recreation center at
Mississippi Valley State University
that's in there too January 1st in
Philly a 32 year old non student was
shot outside a high school after a fight
the guys just walking around to high
school he ends up getting shot he's 32
years old but no that's a school
shooting because they need to make this
number really scary because they need to
politicize tragedy when you take out all
those extraneous incidents the number
becomes 7 school shootings this year and
by the way 7 is bad that's not good that
that number alone should be alarming but
the meme that they use the lefts meme
here is too vastly exaggerated the
numbers and then when you point out the
real numbers you say it's not 22 it's 7
they say what 7 is not enough what
that's that's nothing to you I said no
that that's a big deal but you're the
one lying and multiplying it by more
than three times what it actually is you
see this all the time here's just a
quick little rundown from the mainstream
media and in that time they have been 20
mass shootings 20 mass shootings in the
u.s. we have a pattern now of mass
shootings in this country that
has no parallel anywhere else in the
world there you you heard at the end
there is Barack Obama it has no parallel
anywhere else in the world 20 mass
shootings now of course the number just
changes because they've just redefined
mass shooting however they want to do it
in order to make the numbers seem as big
as possible but what Barack Obama just
said also isn't true we don't we aren't
amout lighter when you compare it to the
rest of the world we're not even an
outlier when you compare mass shootings
in the u.s. to Europe when you define
mass shooting to exclude gang violence
and terrorist attacks as any reasonable
person would mass shooting rates in the
United States are on par with Europe
they're actually a little bit lower
there below Norway there below Macedonia
there below Serbia Slovakia Finland
Belgium and the Czech Republic
we're below all of those but that
doesn't jive with the scare tactics they
want to say the u.s. is crazy it's just
totally crazy out here the implication
being the United States has a second
Amendment we need to get rid of that but
when you look at the actual numbers
we're about where everyone else is
here's here's another one from CNN and
Jimmy Kimmel tweeted this so you know
that's how you know it isn't funny is
when Jimmy Kimmel tweets something CNN
wrote quote the US has had 57 times as
many school shootings as the other major
industrialized nations combined 288
school shootings since 2009 288 whoa I
don't remember that do you remove the
news breathlessly reports any of these
things 288 I don't I don't know that
didn't happen did it
those numbers are pushed by anti-gun
groups anti Second Amendment groups in
particular every town for gun safety
which is Mike Bloomberg's group so a
Jeff Greenfield who's a longtime
contributor to CNN CBS ABC PBS NBC just
every three-letter mainstream media
left-wing hack shop he said and February
2018 quote in the rest of the world
there have been 18 school shootings in
the last 20 years in the u.s. there have
been 18 since January first even
politifact which is a left-leaning
website rated that statement mostly
false this was a statement made by a
well-respected member
of the mainstream media who has worked
for every mainstream media outlet
practically that there is and he's
getting his information like so many of
the others from every town for gun
safety and just look the left does this
I did a Praeger video recently about
language how the left uses language and
twists language to change the narrative
and to control the culture they use the
word every town for gun safety not
travel through Texas travel through the
South travel through the Midwest I don't
think those towns are the towns that
want to abridge our Second Amendment in
frigid on our gun ownership rights in
the country but they say every time
because they said look we all agree we
all agree every time for gun safety so I
thought you were talking about gun
control no gun safety because I have a
safety on my gun there's a little safety
switch like plug it up click it down
that's my gun safety I don't think
they're advocating for that I think they
want to take away the guns so every town
includes among their counting's of all
of these so-called shootings they
include on January 3rd East Olive
elementary school in Michigan a man
committed suicide in that school parking
lot that's a mass shooting that's the
school shootings Coronado elementary in
Arizona a student committed suicide on
the bathroom there were no other
injuries sad story not what we think of
when we think of a school shooting not
of mass shooting
Murphy high in Alabama student fired a
gun into the air outside of school after
an argument I don't maybe that's just
how they celebrate down in Alabama you
know like that was the one with the big
mustache on Looney Tunes anyway nobody
was injured and that counts as a mass
school shooting here is a Democrat
running for governor in Florida here's
what he's saying we send our children
off to school we want to know they're
safe but here in Florida despite 14
school shootings in eight years we still
have some of the weakest gun laws in the
nation that's Philip Levine not true not
true
flat outlines so how does he get to that
number fourteen school shootings in the
last five minutes or whatever ridiculous
scare claim he's making well March 2012
and a pistol at the Episcopal School of
Jacksonville a Spanish teacher was fired
and the disgruntled employee went and
killed the his boss basically the head
of the school then killed himself
it's now what we think of when we think
of a school shooting January 2013 there
was a shooting in Fort Myers a 27 year
old was believed to have been killed by
gangs in retaliation a retaliation
killing for speaking to cops
that's a 27 year old that's not a poor
kid being gunned down in his own school
March 2013 a 30 year old student killed
himself at the University of Central
Florida March 2014 an elementary school
teacher was killed by her husband all
very sad stories but to conflate it with
these mass shootings is just a lie
again even left-leaning PolitiFact rated
that mostly false here's another one
let's roll some more mainstream clips
the school shootings in Orion and at
Washington State are just two among a
startling number of school shootings
this year 22news reveals how many there
have been and how it's affecting people
in western Massachusetts 37 that's how
many school shootings there have been in
the US this year every town for gun
safety calculated the findings local
parents say the statistics are alarming
we saturate ourselves too much we're in
violence our whole culture and it just
doesn't seem you can't do anything about
it it's like throwing a wiffle ball into
the wind what's even more shocking is
the number of school shootings since the
Sandy Hook massacre in December 2012 in
the 18 months since there have been 74
instances of shots fired on school
grounds not true those numbers just are
not right again even politifact even
left-leaning PolitiFact rates that
mostly false when you delve into the
numbers of the 74 this is 74 numbers how
do you get to that number when you get
to actual school shootings at the very
highest count that number is 10 is that
a high number yes
is that number too high yes is it scary
yes is it tragic yes 10 of 74 there were
another 39 that were caused by drug
dealing robbery and personal
altercations that's nearly four times as
many as we would call school shootings
have that incidents outside of school
hours they had nothing to do with the
school people just happen to be walking
onto the school because it's public
property 16 that's a 60% 60% higher than
the number of Acts
school shootings suicide six accidental
discharge 374 incidents that they count
resulted in 38 deaths is that high yes
is that sad yes relative to 74 incidents
though that's a relatively modest number
of deaths because if you say there have
been 74 school shootings what comes up
into people's minds is 10 people killed
in each of these so you have this image
in your mind that I don't know 740 750
people have been killed in one of these
school shootings but really it's 38 and
a lot of suicide a lot are gang-related
a lot or or robbery related nearly half
by the way 35 of them took place at
colleges or universities again you hear
school shooting and the left is so good
at this when they politicize this issue
constantly you think of these poor
little elementary school kids at Sandy
Hook or something half of them are
colleges or universities sometimes
involving non students people in their
30s people who are older whenever guns
are involved there is massive
manipulation that happens on the Left
emotional manipulation statistical
manipulation legal manipulation
emotionally they want to put these
images in your head that are not true
statistically they exaggerate the
numbers legally they try to get around
the Second Amendment contrary to the
mainstream media reporting contrary to
these sad events that do happen from
time to time there has been no spike in
recent decades of children killed at
schools they say that there is an
epidemic going on it's a getting crazy
we have to do something it's it's
getting so much worse in fact in reality
children killed in school shootings are
down 75 percent since the early 1990s
they're not up 75 percent they're not up
100 percent it's fallen 75 percent more
children are killed each year by
swimming pools and bicycles than by mass
shootings in school mass shootings in
general over the past several decades
there have been gun control laws enacted
urban gun control laws repealed they
have had no effect they've had a
negligible effect on these numbers and
that includes the assault weapons ban of
1994 which then expired 10 years later
and that brings us to the gun control
aspect here because in this recent very
sad shooting there was no ar-15 used in
the recent shootings the left in order
to push gun control and to politicize
these tragedies has
said we need to ban semi-automatic
rifles ar-15 since the semi automatic
semi-automatic means you pulled the
trigger once in a bullet comes out we
know that five times as many people each
year are murdered with knives as with
rifles of any kind including
semi-automatic including ar-15 we know
one and a half times as many people are
killed with baseball bats and clubs and
hammers we know that two times as many
people are killed with hands and feet we
know that over 19 times as many people
are killed with handguns as with rifles
of any kind including air 15 but in this
shooting no ar-15 this was you a shotgun
a revolver and and homemade explosives
Molotov cocktails I mean this was a sick
sick puppy who committed this act but he
wasn't using the ar-15 in fact a shotgun
was pump-action wasn't even
semi-automatic he had to pump the
shotgun which means we're talking about
the simplest gun that there is practice
practically no simpler gun in the
country this isn't some super high-tech
thing very basic gun the gun control
crowd has pounced on the shooting but
what are they gonna say now they can't
say hey this scary-lookin gun we need to
just ban this one because now we're
talking bout the most basic on there is
so guess I think to the heart of the
argument to help us make sense of the
media reaction I have got two guys here
who have a lot of experience in the
media spotlight on gun control
Kyle Kashyap and Kenneth Preston we're
gonna talk to them in just one second
but before and now that now that I'm you
know that we have them here it's gonna
be expert opinion and discussion I need
you to listen to a little bit little
bits is really good a wonderful sponsor
and listen you know these guys are these
guys are pretty young 18 19 years old
and we try to reach the youth in this
program so I'm going to tell you about
an award-winning platform of easy to use
electronic building blocks for creating
inventions large and small I have this
to send to my nephew because I wasn't I
wasn't gonna keep the it's a it's a toy
it's a really cool sophisticated toy
from little bits it's the complete droid
kit it looks really neat I wasn't gonna
build it myself you know I kind of feel
like I'm a little old for that I don't
know meanwhile I walked down the hallway
at the Daily wire all the thirty year
olds are pouring out begging me to have
the toy I'm sending it to my little
whew this is amazing six bits 20 droid
parts three sticker sheets a free app
app has step by step instructions video
tutorials drive mode force mode self
navigation 20 authentic droid sounds
from the Star Wars films it's just if
this toy had been out when I was a kid I
was also sort of a Star Wars fanatic I
would have gone crazy for it
22 missions more than 22 missions in the
app to teach the droid new skills
customize new droids give them
personality coding it's really really
cool I'm very lucky I never know what to
get my nephews you know for Christmas or
whatever the holiday so I send this over
this is the toy because I looked it up
too everyone is saying this is like the
toy of the year it actually won the toy
Association's 2018 12 the year so get it
for your kids and inspire invention I
really you can't go wrong this is such a
cool toy
my nephew really really likes it visit
little bits comm slash Noel's K no W l
es just like Jay Z's wife for $10 off a
droid inventor kit don't say I never did
nothing for you little bits dot-com
slash Noel's ko wles
$10 off Detroit inventor kit gentlemen
thank you for being here we've got Kyle
cash of Kenneth Preston what are you
guys doing in town oh we were at a
convention a few days ago a gun
convention and we've just been going
around and seeing this deplorable city
city well I gotta say you make very
astute observations you have become
because I've had you both on my show
before and we came on after the shooting
at your high school you came on to talk
about the media reaction this media
frenzy that came around the high school
and then Kenneth you produced this
incredible report I think you're the
last journalist in America it's you and
Cheryl Atkinson at you actually produce
this investigative report on all of the
abuses all the total failures of Broward
County that led to that shooting that
they they might have a lot of guilt on
their hands for allowing this guy to
slip through the cracks in the meantime
since I've talked to you both you have
become a Twitter storm Kyle you are it
is one of the best Twitter accounts on
the internet thank you it you are making
these observations I think you're doing
better than perhaps some other young
activists around the country I would
agree I'm sure you would so I want to
begin a Kyle you are recently I saw this
tweet you are currently ranked number
one in your high school right there you
don't go on CNN as much as members of
your high school class but you are
ranked now they cut me off they cut you
CNN cut you off supposed to go on and
they they cut off from the internet
interview did they really
ya know backed out it's is it it's well
I've wondered what it what's the
difference what is it about you that my
I couldn't tell you I I don't know what
it is I obviously couldn't yes yeah so
you're number one year class by the way
I hate to break this to you there's no
way that your teachers and school
administration are never gonna let you
be valedictorian that is just not gonna
happen I've doubled down on taking more
classes this summer yes you're really
sure yeah what do you what classes are
you taking I'm taking like three random
college classes that I've never heard of
before just to make sure I solidified
number one I don't know if I took three
classes in college either I did a lot of
things in college I don't have I don't
three whole classes yeah in a serious
note do you find it hard you've become
this media celebrity since the shooting
because you came out and said enough is
enough with the the media manipulation
here yeah I call yes
you called BS on it you happen to be a
supporter of the Second Amendment that
was very taboo do you find it's hard to
manage remaining a high school students
staying number one in your class and
having all of this attention on you oh
yeah definitely like I have to make sure
I don't slip up in any way shape or form
I'm gonna be the media will definitely
jump on it specifically at school I get
a lot of hate
I get staredown at school really
absolutely like I keep a tracker every
day of how many people stay redound it's
close to like 2 to 3 people every day do
you is the schools very left-wing yes
very of course I call schools are
certainly that and now but you become a
Twitter celebrity all in all I'm very
happy about that because you have a
great perspective Kenneth you have
produced this serious body of work
serious allegations against local
officials
it was briefly reported by some people
in the conservative media and basically
it's been blacked out and no one is
reporting on this what's going on
well there was a
but for just a moment and and exactly as
you said it disappeared
we had some traction Marco Rubio called
for an investigation into some of our
claims so you know behind the scenes
things are going on but really local
officials local media nobody's covering
him the interesting thing though is that
we finally had they were denying for
months that any of the information was
true or correct in the superintendent
had to come out and finally admit to the
fact that they were misleading at the
beginning they said that the student was
never part of these disciplined programs
would in fact a reporter revealed but
that the student was he was referred to
the shooter was part of these different
programs and because of the policies of
Broward County right he was not
processed they said oh we're gonna sweep
this under the rug
basically and they denied that from the
beginning and finally it came to light
that that was the truth this is this is
really interesting work and it actually
shows something in the culture both of
you guys because the mainstream media
they try to create a big show they try
to create the illusion of popular
support but it's it seems astroturfed
doesn't it you know you're you're doing
you know some of your classmates will go
on TV and and just lie safe fate fakes
logistics slander US senators and civil
rights advocates and they're lauded and
applauded the minute that you contravene
that orthodoxy in the media the minute
you start going after the media they
turn on you they try to shut you down
you you have some issues at school but
also issues with the local law
enforcement officials i I do want your
thoughts off broadly because I've tried
to only focus these conversations on the
media the media have descended on
Parkland and Broward County this debate
has gone on a long time and it's in its
most recent iteration in this recent
shooting at the Santa Fe Texas the
killer was on the honor roll the killer
was a football player
the killer was apparently just a regular
high school student there weren't a lot
of signs there we didn't fall through
the cracks of disciplinary programs as
far as we know and yet people demand no
more never again we need to do something
we need to prevent these
happening again is there a chance that
this just was not preventable well yeah
definitely I mean there are certain
aspects where it could have been
prevented had there been the proper
school resource officers on campus being
able to defend it that's why you see the
kids calling we want to arm schools we
wanted like Hardin schools but I think
fundamentally what the left is proposing
for like the for the shooting to happen
in my school would not have stopped the
the Texas shooting that we see right now
that's that's a really good point it
didn't didn't even occur to me you're
right if you have people there who can
physically stop these shooting because
once the shooter is on campus you're
screwed unless you have someone like the
cliches that only a good guy with the
gun can stop a bad guy with the gun but
it's true no right and that's the only
way you can stop them yeah that's right
just to call it a cliche doesn't mean it
isn't true it's obviously it is
obviously true I want to know you know
our pal around here you know we
broadcast from the broom closet of the
ben shapiro show the guy who broadcasts
from the studio of the ben shapiro show
he says facts don't care about your
feelings but it seems like the gun
control activists and the media don't
care about facts I mean we just ran
through all of those bogus statistics
that they are breathlessly reporting
support for stricter gun laws is at the
highest level it's been since 1993 and
despite the fact that no gun law
proposed in recent years would have
prevented any of these shootings how can
we combat that perception do what is the
way to get people to care about facts on
the gun debate well I think it's it's
not necessarily just a gun debate it's
it's something that should be looked at
as a multi-faceted issue and I think the
way to do that is to bring them the fact
that look it whatever you're feeling is
on guns
there were systemic failures that led to
the body count that day systemic
failures and to show them that to
present the evidence and to now what
we're doing is running school board
members and showing them that there is a
better way I believe that once we
implement those changes and things start
to fix themselves that the conversation
is gonna begin to shift that's such a
that's such a good point and to hear you
speak about this you sound like adults
the reason you know I was real I got it
I have to admit I was very hesitant at
first to talk to you guys about gun
control because I don't catch certainly
should be well because I think just
because a 17 year old or an
eighteen year old has lived through some
experience that doesn't make him an
expert on constitutional law or crime
prevention and then CNN put your
classmates on TV immediately and said
get emotional get but to hear you talk
about it you you're not impassioned and
calling people names and you're looking
at this in a very systematic way and
saying oh maybe that maybe that law if
that if that law hadn't been in place
the heat this guy would have been caught
if this policy had been enforced if this
money had been spent if you can actually
do it in a very rational and systematic
way that is utterly missing from the
debate on this issue I want to know what
is next for you guys you're the last
journalist in America Kenneth what's
next what can we look for from you where
can we find you sure right right now I
would all I'm doing is working on school
board races ensuring that the current
leadership is not here come November so
that we can harden our schools what we
want to do is make sure that Broward
County is an example to the rest of the
country of what a school district can be
and after that just continuing to expose
some elected officials that have some
some answering to do it's great work
because it's not glamorous
first of all running those races is not
glamorous I've run a bunch of small
races running them as not glamorous
covering local politics is not glamorous
but it is the most important work in
politics so god speed with that Kyle
we're just following you on Twitter I
will continue bashing liberals with
their leftist tears every single day on
Twitter and I'm going to make sure I
fight for the Second Amendment non-stop
you know it's it is a more glamorous way
of life I will say having done it myself
it's very fun and very important
gentlemen so good to see you I look
forward to seeing you guys next time
you're back in town I've got to say
goodbye to you people before we get to
the news we have so much good news today
we a guy you know Donald Trump calls
ms-13 animals the mainstream media
defend them they say they're not animals
and then an ms-13 guy is literally named
animal he gets sentenced to 40 years in
jail for murdering a 15 year old boy
we'll get to that we will get to all of
the lies about Harvey Milk we will get
to the stain history but you gotta go to
Daley wire.com go there right now why it
is $10 a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the end
reclaim ensure you get the Ben Shapiro
show ask questions in the mailbag ask
questions on the conversation I don't
I'll give you a back rub or something I
don't know what it comes with but you
get
the leftist years tumblr here it is here
it is folks the when that guy you're
gonna have 40 years of leftist tears as
a mr. animal from ms the routine is
rotting away in prison as we talk about
the reality of Harvey Milk go there
right now daily wire.com we'll be right
back
all right so we've got a lot of news to
get to today really cool to talk to
those guys by the way let's try to run
through in the last 10 minutes so before
we get to this day in history and Harvey
Milk Donald Trump is a prophet he
actually as a prophet an ms-13 gang
member nicknamed animal receives a 40
year prison sentence this week for
conspiracy to murder a 15 year old boy
Joel Martinez admitted to prosecutors
that he murdered this boy quote I
stabbed the culero three times he stared
at me and he asked me if I was going to
if I was going to stab him I told him
yes the Mara
rules you Maura for the name of his gang
killing people is a requirement for
achieving full status in the
Massachusetts chapter of ms-13 and the
end the left denies this Donald Trump
attacks ms-13 the left begins to
defendant why is it what's going on here
why does it say this seems to be the
case a lot with Trump Trump will say
something and then it'll just happen and
you just say and you saw this throughout
the 2016 campaign say how does he do
this the the reason it's not because
he's Nostradamus it's because Donald
Trump observes reality that's actually
why that's why he was a good marketer
that's why he was a good TV personality
it's why he was good in business he
observes reality he's a people person
so he sees what's actually happening the
mainstream media don't do that the
mainstream media are caught in their own
ideological views of the world you see
this with some conservatives who remain
stubbornly anti Trump I think there's
only one of them left I rights for one
of those legacy conservative magazines
and tweets all the time and but I think
most have come around you know some of
the really anti Trump voices Jonah
Goldberg I was pleased to see said he
would vote for Donald Trump a number of
others you know I've said okay we'll
come along I had been where the Maggie
had a long time ago actually he came
around a long time
and but some people are so they stick in
this despite all of the evidence to the
contrary why is that because they're in
an ideological world just just like the
mainstream media it's just two sides of
the same coin but in the real world of
politics where things are actually
happening in real time that that lower
sea conservatism that's where Donald
Trump is getting everything right and
just because in case you thought that
God sometimes paints with too subtle a
brush a literal sinkhole has now opened
up on the White House lawn pear action
in the swamp an actual sinkhole is
trying to engulf the Trump White House
one opened up over the weekend a second
one opened up next to it
got noticeably bigger between Sunday and
Monday it's over a foot long now oh I
guess you could say all nature is but
art unknown today all chance direction
which thou canst not see this is an
important sign this is a symbol now it
should remind us of something I don't
know how much of reality is being
reflected by the White House lawn but it
is certainly the case that the swamp of
Washington DC is trying to swallow this
president a lot of people took the wrong
lessons from Watergate and we're seeing
some of that play out again there is a
concerted political effort to take down
this president they want him impeached
they want him subpoenaed they want him
prosecuted they want him any way to get
this guy out of office because they
cannot accept the election Democrats are
known for this they couldn't accept the
2000 election they never let that go
they couldn't accept the 2016 election
because they were so sure you're trying
to swallow up this president by any
means necessary it's a really dangerous
thing Republicans don't do this
when Democrats win elections even Barack
Obama who is so awful he was just such a
bad president both in that he was thick
less and undermined American credibility
but also he was so radically left-wing
and obviously didn't like America very
much the reason we know that he didn't
like America very much as he said he
wants to fundamentally transform it and
you don't want to fundamentally
transform things that you like so even
that guy we didn't try to impeach him
there was never any serious effort on
the right to impeach Barack Obama and
that Congress never voted to impeach the
guy but they're trying to get Donald
Trump
ooh this is why we need to rally around
and defend Donald Trump because the
sinkhole on the White House lawn
figurative and literal is trying to
swallow him up hole politics is a team
sport there are parties you play for a
team and it's not frivolous it's not
some little hobby you're on that team
because you believe what that team is
doing you support what that team is
doing the reason that I support Donald
Trump is not because I'm a Republican
I'm a Republican because I believe
certain things I'm a conservative
because I have a vision for the country
Donald Trump is the is the captain of
that team right now and you've got us
supporting even if you don't like the
way he sips Chardonnay even if he
doesn't put his pinkie out the right way
he's the guy he's doing the right thing
and you got to come along as politics is
a team sport and if you try to extract
yourself above that or say oh I don't I
don't want to be on this team that isn't
that isn't how politics is done that
isn't what it is so I urge everybody to
beware of the sinkhole that is about to
swallow up the White House finally
before we get out of here
this day in history we got to talk about
Harvey Milk did you know it's Harvey
Milk day it's a happy Harvey Milk day
everybody do you know that do people
even know who Harvey Milk is no because
they did this this all came about
because Hollywood like it always does
made a totally dishonest film about a
left winger and tried to make him into a
hero and all of a sudden there was all
this Pro Harvey Milk activism Harvey
Milk was a gay activist in San Francisco
in the 1970s he's the first openly gay
elected official in California he ran
for office four times in San Francisco
didn't win most of the time eventually
he got on to the San Francisco Board of
Supervisors he only served there for I
think eleven months before he was
assassinated be not assassinated because
he was gay by the way assassinated by a
political opponent basically who
assassinated a straight guy too they've
created this lionized character of
Harvey Milk in recent years there was a
Sean Penn movie made and he was the
fighter and people were attacking him
because he was gay they tried to bomb
out his store and they assassinated
because he was gay none of that is true
there was a bomb attack on his store but
his friends admitted in later years that
Harvey Milk was probably complicit in
planning that because the campaign
wasn't doing very well to quote them and
he needed to get a little bit more
attention Harvey Milk moved to San
Francisco along with lots of other gay
men in the early 1970s he was finally
elected in 1978 and I mean after this
movie came out the California
established Harvey Milk Day 2009 Barack
Obama awarded him the Presidential Medal
of Freedom that year who is the real
Harvey Milk well what do we know about
the guy we know that he was basically a
pederast cult leader he preyed on a 16
year old runaway named Jack Galen
McKinley the age of consent in
California by the way is 18 years old
you thought that the Republicans had a
problem with Roy Moore to hear the left
talk about Roy Moore you you'd think I
mean and these were allegations that
weren't quite proven there were
discrepancies with some of the evidence
it was in the heat of a political
campaign we hadn't heard about this
before because Roy Moore had a fling
with a 16 year old girl allegedly this
guy Harvey Milk wins the Presidential
Medal of Freedom he had an open
relationship when he was in
30s with a 16 year old runaway boy but
it get it gets worse from there
Harvey Milk was also pals with Jim Jones
where have I heard that name before the
guy who passed around the kool aid
killed nine hundred people at the
People's Temple in Guyana he was good
friends with Jim Jones he wrecked a
Harvey Milk regularly attended the
People's Temple he defended Jim Jones to
Jimmy Carter so there was an inquiry
into Jim Jones because Jim Jones
abducted a six-year-old kid in Guyana
six-year-old little boy and Harvey Milk
wrote to Jimmy Carter and said Jim Jones
is a man of the highest character you've
got he slandered the kid's own parents
who were down there he worked together
with Jim Jones he used them as help for
his campaign at Harvey Milk was he was a
nobody he was a guy of questionable past
he he did believe strongly in promoting
gay political rights and that's all the
left needed to know about him to turn
him into a hero but he wasn't a hero in
his personal life he was an absolute
derelict it was the sort of guy where if
he were a Republican when people would
want that left would want to throw him
in jail but because he supported gay
rights they had to create a narrative
about him and the left always does this
you'll see they'll go on television
they'll say they'll make some outrageous
claim and then when you point out that
it isn't true they'll say yeah it's not
true but it gets to a larger truth what
yeah no it's a lie but a lot but the lie
you know it's a larger truth so how do
you get to them that's because it's all
about illusion it's all about look over
here it's all Hollywood glitz and glamor
and that's what's happened with Harvey
Milk the cartoon character of RV milk
that that Sean Penn played in that movie
has very little if anything to do with
Harvey Milk himself you're seeing this
happen in the mainstream media every
single day so the mainstream media they
say Donald Trump has never been more
unpopular it's over II colluded with
Russia II did this to a porn story bla
bla bla bla bla all of this noise right
and yet we look at the polling Trump is
still quite popular more popular or as
popular as Barack Obama on the relative
days of their presidency the economy is
doing well
electoral chances are looking good I
don't want to jinx it but maybe what
tomorrow we'll go into some of the data
on those races things on in reality when
you talk to people in reality are
looking pretty good don't be fooled by
the left-wing
don't be fooled by Harvey Milk day don't
be fooled by Hollywood don't be fooled
by the New York Times or CNN or The
Washington Post take a look around
reality because when people look at
reality they're they're able to predict
the future they're able to do very well
they're able to see kind of what's in
the air what's going on and we've we've
seen that with the Donald Trump movement
it's an important political lesson to
gather from president cough fa we'll
have much more cough fa tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt Oh tune in tomorrow
I've only got a couple shows left before
I head off to my wedding folks if you
want to send me celebratory wedding
Cuban cigars and bars of gold and piles
of money let me know I'll see you
tomorrow I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you